or ça fait partie de l'histoire du
québec
le village de fortier ville au centre du
c'est ici qu'ont vécu la petite aurore
mais les gens qui arrivent pour venir
visiter le monument d'horreur c'est le
premier endroit où il vient son temps
après son décès personne ne l'a oublié
et elle y glisse fait partie de
l'histoire d'aurore beaucoup sans
autopsie a eu lieu ici
la mairesse participera à une messe ici
le mois prochain ce sera le point
culminant des commémorations qui ont
débuté aujourd'hui aussi un élément
important
le centre d'interprétation et d'histoire
de forcier ville je vous emmène du côté
dédié à aura son histoire yvonne la
chance est responsable de ce centre
un vrai petit musée elle y dirige des
visites guidées chaque semaine d'année
en année c'est au moins mille visiteurs
par année
des meubles des livres des costumes des
photos une grande partie de l'exposition
est dédiée à la petite fille tristement
célèbre c'est qu'elle fait partie de
notre histoire notre village a vécu ses
pairs cet événement là on ne peut pas
savoir dissocier non plus loin possible
je vois qu'il ya quand même une place
importante qui est fait au film
ben c'est que ça reste quand même dans
l'imaginaire collectif les films que
tous nos jeux dans les cheveux trop soit
perçue
quand le film est sorti le sujet trop
jeunes doivent les vagues allaient
laisser plus tard quand les gens me
reconnaissent aide je vois des décennies
après l'avoir interprété au cinéma
yvonne la flamme se souvient toujours
très bien du moment où elle a dû se
mettre dans la peau d'aurore l'effroi le
poil je ne ferai pas brûler les
specialty sils tech ou comment je
réagirais si de rien n'était mais ce
poids à leur résister résister aux mots
donner à ta fort que la madame admettait
les mains sur le pôle plage avec la
coqueluche ancien me faire bouder les
mêmes
c'était ma responsabilité je pense elle
avait tout d'abord la caisse qu'elle
aurait vécu à ce moment là la frayeur la
panique
une photo à l'école et une photo sur le
perron de sa maison
au delà des photos une façon d'honorer
la mémoire d'aurore et de mieux protéger
les enfants au québec hugues létourneau
a été avocat pour la dpj pendant près de
40 ans la situation d'horreur et de la
situation de l'enfant de granby sont
pour moi des situations quand on a donc
échappé comme société il a assisté à la
création de la loi sur la protection de
la jeunesse qu'il qualifie de
révolutionnaire
ce qui n'empêche pas que des failles
demeure à mon avis on vit dans une
société plus complexes et peut-être plus
de risques pour les enfants
maintenant moi qu'un cheminée j'ai vécu
un peu d'un même milieu avec les mêmes
parrain du monocle et ma tante les
grands-parents de tout ce monde est
assez à proximité il veut pas j'ai
l'impression qu'il y avait des
interventions qui se faisait pour lui la
leçon est sans doute la soie d'être plus
attentifs au sort des enfants autour de
nous ce qui est arrivé on peut pas le
changer
qu'est ce qu'on fait maintenant avec ce
pour honorer la mémoire d'aurore la
mairesse veut plus que des symboles
elle aimerait créer une charte pour
encourager les municipalités du québec à
mettre en place des actions pour mieux
protéger les enfants
on dit souvent ça prend un village pour
élever un enfant moi j'ai envie que l'on
dise après village pour protéger
l'enfant
moi je pensais plus beau cadeau qu'on
peut pas lui donner à oran de faire en
sorte que sa courte vie avait pas été
vaine puisqu'elle ça serve à quelque
chose même si sentant plus tard comment
vous croyez qu'on doit se souvenir de
rang avec mot de compassion beaucoup de
tristesse et beaucoup d'affection une
affection partagé par tous ici même
un siècle plus tard